Hello, welcome to my talk. So the topic
of my talk is Rust is a language of AGI,
artificial general intelligence. I
explain why it's about Rust tools for AI
coders and their human assistants. You
read it right the AI first, human
second. That's you know um I say I
believe it's a lot of how things are
evolving. So, my name is Michael Yu and
uh um you can so this link and this PR
code goes my goes to my GitHub page
where you can find my email and contact
information X account and you know
things like that and you can also see
some of the open source projects that
I'm involved in including this project
that I want to talk to you about called
Rust Coder. Anyway, this is a AI
conference. So I think may it may be
prudent to get started with uh a little
bit background about what is Rust and
Rust as you know is a programming
language. It's hard to believe it's just
celebrated 10 years anniversary. So it's
took a long time to grow a programming
language and one of its distinctions is
that people love it. You know that's uh
um
so since the stack overflow has its
developer survey thrust is the most
beloved program language every single
year in the past 10 years it's it just
celebrates it 10 year anniversary right
so pretty much since it was born it was
very beloved by the programming
community uh so this is this year's
data but you can also see some of
the I would say troubles or the signs
you know that's uh so you can see let's
let from the top it's Python,
JavaScript, SQL, HTML, TypeScript, Rust
and Go, right? And you can see the red u
the red bar is how people admire the
language. People really admire and
really love Rust. It has 82%. It's much
higher than anyone else than anything
else that's in this list, right? You
know that's But what about the blue? The
blue is actually desired how much people
want to actually use it right you know
so in that measurements python is really
high and rust is not really that high
but surprisingly it's higher than than
go right you know so you know that's
brings to the issue rust is a language
that people really love for many reasons
which I going to get into why but also
people find
it's diff somewhat difficult or somewhat
they are hesitant to use
themselves. Why? Because for humans,
Rust has a very steep learning curve.
Okay? So, you know, so there's a um you
can you can just search for Rust
learning curve on internet. You can see
a lot of examples and people find it's
difficult to learn because it has a very
powerful compiler that forces you to do
the right thing. You can do a lot of
things that are not only wrong, you
know, that's not only not optimal but
also very bug plume in languages like
C++ or in languages like Python,
JavaScript, they're not even a compiler,
right? You know, so it's just a um so
you can anything goes right in no strong
type system and all that. So, Rust
forces you to write from write the
correct and optimized code from the
get-go and that is apparently very
difficult for beginners and I have to
say I went through the same learning
curve when I started to learn Rust. The
the good news of course is once you
master that it's uh it become a lot
easier to write correct code in Rust
than any other language but the initial
um learning curve is hard to get over.
So that's one of the big issues with
Rust, right?
However, that's the humanentric world.
The humanentric world, we want a
language that easy to write. Maybe it
has bugs, but then we can get the result
quicker, right? You know, maybe it's
hard to maintain, but you know, that's
uh let's have something working first.
So, that's why Python, JavaScript are so
popular. Rust is not that language. So,
what is Rust good for? So I I I think
there's a very enlightening talk um you
know by in the latent space podcast by
Brett Brett Taylor you know who's uh you
know um the chairman of open AI and you
know very famous guy and uh so he
basically said the human would prefer
Python over Rust um because you you know
it's easier but Rust is better suited
for machines not only because it's more
efficient but because it's all more
structurally orient Ed for the strong
compiler checking the strong type system
and all that it's just more rigorous and
uh because the compiler provide a very
tight feedback loop you know one of the
experiences that a lot of Rust developer
have is that there's little debugging
out once the project compiles you know
once your Rust project compiles there's
a high likelihood it's going to run
correctly you know and it's a it would
run as you intended you know that's um
so the same can't be said by mean many
other languages especially languages
without compilers but though because of
this because this property the the
compiler of the rust language provide a
very good feedback loop for the AI so it
forces AI to gen it creates what we call
a very good reward function right you
know so if you think about reinforcement
learning which is where popularized by
say I mean the large language model
space it's popularized by deepseek you
know in a in a general space popularized
by say alpha go alpha zero right you
provide uh you um for any for any
question or any request you have a
correct answer in the world of rust is
what's the compiler accepts right it
provide a very strong feedback to the uh
to the large language model so it can
get really good at those things so
that's why we say uh a programming like
a programming language like rust maybe
it's difficult for humans but it's a per
really a perfect fit for AI code
generators. So if we if we see a future
where most of the code is written by AI,
I would think that's you know to have AI
write human incomprehensible Python or
JavaScript is not the way to go because
those language the benefit of those
languages are human comprehensible right
you know if you are going to write code
that is hard for humans but easy for AI
but you can use you can fairly easily
verify its correctness then Rust would
be the way to go right you know so
that's a background you know that's why
we think you know in the in the world of
AI in the world of generated code ROS a
language like Rust is so important
because it's friendly to the AI and also
reasonably friendly to the humans so
what do we want to do so that's why we
uh started a project called Rust coder
with a very specific goal of um making
uh Rust
more teaching Rust to AI and making AI
generator generate better Rust code
right so this project by the way it's
sponsored by two uh internship grants
from the Linux Foundation. You can think
of this as you know Google Summer of
Code that type of thing but paid for and
sponsored by Linux Foundation and it use
cooperated materials from the uh
educational materials from the rust
foundation as well. So um the goal of
this rust coder project really is for
humans make it easier makes the AI
assistant of learning rust make it
easier to learn rust to wipe code with
rust and
to make rust easier to work with in ids
for instance but perhaps more
importantly as we'll see in a minute for
machines make it possible to generate
rust code on the flies for instance um
one thing that people do believe is that
the path to agi may come from code
generators right you know If the large
language model planned for something and
it want to execute on it, it could call
core API or it could generate code to
perform this task for it, right? You
know, so this so we our goal is to make
it easier for machine to generate
correct Rust code and to make it Yeah.
So, you know, you give it a specific
task. it can generate code on the fly
and make sure that the code by working
with the compiler to make sure that the
code is correct you know at least can
correctly execute right so that's the
goal of the rust coder project so first
I'll show a a demo that is help humans
learn rust and uh there's a link here
that's um goes into the process so the
process really is that we take rust
education materials and we um asked our
um um software interns to generate um
several hundreds of tasks that's um you
know common Rusk developer would do and
uh build that into a knowledge base by
creating embeddings put that into vector
database and all that and build a system
where you can ask a programming question
or asking a programming task to the AI
agent and the AI agent would be able to
give you um you know a Rust answer right
you know
so let's See a
demo. In this test, the student needs to
write a Rust program to convert numbers
to different bases. This is a complex
problem. Let's see if a CHV coder model
running on Gaia network can pass this
test. We are accessing this GA node from
the cursor
IDE. In cursor's AI assistant panel,
we'll first give it the
question. Since this is a complex
question, we'll also give it some
examples like this input get this
output. Finally, we we'll tell it to
implement it in Rust so that it wouldn't
do it in Python or
JavaScript. Now, we send the question
and everything to the GIA node that runs
the chairman coder model. It immediately
start to give the answers as well as the
code that implements its answer.
After that it even give the explanation
of the
code. It tell you how the how it
structure the the data and uh the
purpose of different functions in the
code. Now I'll just copy the entire code
and put that into the main IDE.
After that I can go ahead and run cargo
wrong which would compile and run the
application and it gives the right
result.
So now have you have seen a demo here is
u um this project is actually used by
over a thousand developers that in a in
a um in a university bait based rust
camp and one of the questions that you
have just saw are the exam questions and
uh so all essentially all the exam
questions are like that and the rust
coder would be able to do it in one shot
and we would be able to explain it
answers to the um to the learner and uh
help them explore more. Right? So this
is the first
demo. Now let's look at the second demo
because that's more wide coding you know
that's uh you have a instruction and
generate some rusted code that is you
know it's has similar examples in the
database in a vector database. Now we
want to do something that is more
advanced that is to help humans coding
rust in the IDE right. So for that we
made a MCP server in the in the rust
coder. So in the same same approach we
can integrate MCP server into cursor IDE
right. So we provide several MCP tools
that allow cursor to generate a new
project and compile and fix a existing
project. So here's a demo.
So here you can see I have cursor opened
up and uh in the cursor MCP servers I
have added a local rust decoder MCP
server and uh you can go to our
documentation to find out how to do that
and you can see once connected it's
available at localhost port 3000 so it's
uh it's running entirely on my local
machine and you can see it creates two
tools one one tool is called generate
so the the generate MCP tool um allows
you to give it a description and and
then a requirement both in string format
and uh it would generate the whole
um um a whole Rust project for you um
because it has a vector database that
has many common you know um algorithms
and Rust use cases and you know things
like that. So you can find a template
and then um based on your description
modify the template and generate for
you. But I want to show you today really
is that the oh so let me refresh this so
that get back. So but what I really want
to show you here today is the compile
and fix. So compile and effect is a MCP
tool that allows you to take um files um
Rust project files um in the context and
then ask the large language model to
send that to send those files to the MCP
server so that the MCP server compiles
it using its own Rust compiler to
compile it. uh if it encounter any
error, it's going to use the error to
use its own large language model, a
coding large language model to figure
out what the error is and uh then
attempt to fix the source code and after
the after it try to fix it, it is going
to run the compiler again. It's going to
repeat until it gets a um gets the right
results. So this tool I believe is
pretty useful you know when used with um
ids because it allows uh because it
allows you to just give your rust
project to the to the MCP and have it
automatically fix the bugs. Right? So
what are we going to do is that I going
to um go to because I have a rust
project open and you can see it's a very
simple project. it's uh just to print
hello world and uh it's obviously wrong
because there's no closing there, right?
You know, so the syntax is wrong. So
what I going to do is that I in a in
agent chat I going to tell it
to compile the Rust project file in the
context. So two files in the context
cargo. And Rust main rs and fix all the
compiler bugs.
Go. So cursor sees my request and sees
the files in the context and it knows
the best way to do that is to call the
MCP tool that I've just that's connected
called compile and fix. So I'm going to
say run the
tool. Oh, so it's really fast. So it
comes back and says the syntax error is
this. So just uh you know adding those.
So you can we can just accept this and
then now fixed it's can the the code can
compile now. But before we go, let's go
into the tool and see what's
being what's the request and response.
So the request really is so it sends two
files here. One is file name cargo tommo
and the content of this file bene
underneath it and then start a new
section called file src main.rs and then
the file that's seen here that's the
broken main.rs that wouldn't pass the
compiler. So we send that to the tool
and the response from the tool is still
the entire the the source code of the
entire package. So it has a file name
tommo.co.tomo and then
the source main rs. But you can see it
fixed this already. So this by having
this results coming back from the MCP
tool the building um large language
model inside cursor would be able to
figure out what's the difference and
then tell you and then it also
intelligent enough to know that's this
is a hint so it going to just fix this
and then it ask it goes back to the
editor and ask to fix it. Now I know you
must be asking you know that's for
simple example like that the building
rust compiler and building large
language model like cloud uh inside
cursor can probably figure it out as
well after all it's just missing a you
know missing something obvious right um
but what I would like to note is that uh
for tools like um the rust coder MCP
server it's a fully integrated solution
with zone knowledge base of all the the
rust compiler error messages and how to
fix those error messages. And as you use
it, the knowledge base also grows,
right? Because sometimes it can't fix
it, but cursor would give a different uh
answer or you would give a different
answer. So it would know, it would learn
as it goes how to fix this type of
issues and uh it's integrated with its
own prompt, its knowledge base and its
own large language uh large language
model. uh in this particular case we use
uh the GA network and nama edge to run a
um chancoder model right you know so
it's have all these things packaged
together so it's a whole package that's
gets more intelligent about rust
development over time so I believe it's
going to be a lot better than say using
um the generic coding large language
models that's available in cursor which
is really designed for python and
javascript and such but knows a little
bit of rust. So it can solve easy rust
problems but probably not the big
ones. All right. So now you have seen
the demo. So let's recap how it works,
right? So there's a MCP tools that um
two MCP tools. One generate a project
and then then compile and fix any errors
as you can see. And uh so under the hood
it's a integrated stack of several tools
that work together that has been
fine-tuned and to and programmed that
they call each other and knows each
other's behavior so that they all work
together to complete those tasks. So we
have coding large language models that
you can use commercial you can configure
to use commercial ones or use open
source ones. um in this partic um you
know so in this particular case we're
using open source model that's chairman
encoder it optimized for the prompt
tailored to the model so each model
takes a different prompt so for instance
the gamma 3 model would not have a
system prompt so you have to put the
system prompt in the in the user message
right for others you can put the code in
context into the system prompt so
there's different variations and what
type of language that the model responds
to right and then most importantly a
self-improve ing knowledge base of Rust
compiler error messages. So Rust
compiler has a lot of error messages and
we gave examples if this error message
is typically triggered if the code looks
like this and this is how to fix it. So
but we can't cover all of them. So one
of the goal of this uh long-term goal of
this project is for people to contribute
this knowledge back into the knowledge
base so that it can be more intelligent.
you can search more relevant examples
and allow it to fix even uh error more
complex you know error messages right so
the text stack behind that's all open
source so we have a llama age project
which is um based on Linux foundation
project that runs large language model
and AI models everywhere so you know so
uh you may think this is oh maybe this
is a llama cp or lama but no it's uh it
actually it's more like python it runs a
large variety of different models just
not not just large language models but
things also like yolo whisper TTS stable
diffusion and all that stuff runs all
those models and runs across many
different GPUs and MPUs but other than
uh unlike Python it is much much smaller
so it's only measured in tens of
megabytes the runtime itself tens of
megabytes instead of gigabytes for
PyTorch right and uh um then on top of
that we have integrated knowledge base
as we have mentioned is is a core part
of the system. So it has um vortex
search using elastic search. It has you
and also vortex search use tidb and also
um vector search use quadrron and it has
also various um vector embedding models
that you can choose from. So that's all
packaged into uh a product that build on
llama ages called GAA network which you
can I would also encourage you to check
it out and then we turn that into MCP
server using the M open MCP proxy and
this is its own open source project and
uh please go check it out if you have
time. So now we have seen you know h um
how do we use the g and the rust coder
project to help humans right to help
them getting started with rust
programming w program and uh debug your
rust program but I think even more even
larger potential that's um you know
that's would happen in the near future
is MCP is not really for humans although
we are using it for humans at this
moment it's really for machines So we
take a little step back through the
memory lane you know who are the real
user of computers right you know so
that's in early days or maybe 15 years
ago it was mostly humans that's why we
have the web UI we have desktop we have
mobile UI and all that it's all geared
towards humans the human with their eyes
with their fingers you know we can the
multi touch is you know it's is the UI
is designed for human fingers right you
know so the humans are human computer
interface and then the API error comes
you know the API first approach meaning
develop your applications as API first
not as the you human interface first
meaning at that time the consumer would
be a computer you know some other
computer or some other workflow engine
would consume your services you know as
a API there's um many big u many very
successful company grow out of that era
so for instance stripe right it's a
payment solution it's pretty much only
API you know that's uh um you know it's
integrated into another application that
actually has a UI right and uh uh TibLau
is another one right you know sending uh
you accessing the the the telecom
infrastructure the the list go on there
are many many applications like that but
since um large language model come out I
think two use become one of the ways
that um your software and your
application can be consumed by its user
now the user is no longer a computer
that is uh deterministic but fairly
dumb. It can only follow certain rules.
It be the large language model that
behave like humans but it's really
computers. So you know that's where we
have the MCPS the two calls right you
know. So we provide we provide our
services in this in this particular case
we provide the rust compiler service. We
also provide the large language model
based bug fixing service as a tool for
other language large language model to
use. So you can envision a future where
we build a system that is not IDE but
say to control a drone you know that's a
so the rusted code generated is to um is
to direct where the drone going to fly
and how would they behave in certain
circumstances it would just generate
that code using the SDK that is
specified that is um the rust to create
that's included in the knowledge base of
the MCP server and uh then you know
automatically
compile and debug until it works and is
get uploaded to the drone and then the
drone fly out and do whatever whatever
the AI wants it to do right entirely
without human intervention you know but
with reasonable guarantees of the
correctness of the code that been
generated right so that's our long-term
vision for the Rust decoder project I
know it's a big big vision but you know
that's uh um you know that's what where
we want to go in in the world of AGI
Okay.
So at the last section of this talk, so
I would just
uh give you a little bit um you know um
because we talked about how to use a
rust coder, what is used for and how do
you use it, but we haven't really talked
about what's inside it, you know, how do
you get started and you know things like
that. So the rust coder is part of the
program we call local rust and here's
the URL and the the u the QR code. Um
please do go visit it. So it's a set ROS
tools for computers right you know so
Rust coder is one of those and uh so it
provide like I said provide APIs and MCP
services. So the API allow you to work
with workflow engines or deterministic
software programs and MCP allows it to
work with large language models which I
believe in the in the world of um you
know autonomous agents both would play
very important role. So it provides
services in both interfaces right. So to
install and run it is really easy. So it
has a GitHub repository. You can just
clone it and then it has a um you know
docker compos script. So anywhere where
you have docker desktop installed you
can just run docker compose up and uh it
would spin up all the containers right
and connect to the appropriate large
language model uh coding large language
model that you specify. It has a vector
database embedded in it.
So once you install and run you'll be
able to access the APIs for workflow
managers. Here are examples of two APIs
that we talk about. So we talked about
the um how to use it as MCP right but
here you can see you can just use it as
web service APIs as well. So you can
generate and by passing it a JSON object
that has the description and the
requirements it going to generate the
files in that rust project that meets
your description right you know so it's
um um and then follow-up tools would be
able to separate out those files and
save them and you know things like that
which we have seen that in in IDE that's
the cursor can already do that when it
see things like that it knows which file
is operating and then it would be to
write into that file so you can build
your own tools to do that as well. You
know, if you have autonomous agents work
that you have to do, right? And then the
second is compile and fix errors. So
it's the same as we have just seen in
our uh in your cursor demo which is you
know send um you know flat combine all
the files in your project into one
single flat text file and separated by
certain markers and then send that to
the API and the API would run the Rust
compiler would run the large language
model to fix any errors and then return
the um the whole project in the same
format back to you. So you can from that
point on you can continue to process it,
right?
And you know that's uh obviously with
API uh we also have MCP service which is
the same as you know so it's just using
a command. So the documentation here
just shows how to use a command line MCP
client instead of cursor to um but if
you um in any you know I would say
modern agent framework today um you
would have MCP integration. So so you
have to figure out how to integrate MCP
servers into your framework. But um once
you do that it's just a very standard
tool cost that you can ask your large
language model to figure out when to
generate code in Rust and when to fix
the compile and fix code in Rust. Right?
So those are yeah that's pretty much um
all I want to cover in this talk. Um uh
what I want to emphasize is this is
pretty much a work in progress and uh um
so our um second um you know Linux
Foundation internship is still ongoing
and the progress is being tracked by um
on GitHub in this issue. So if you're
interested um you know um come check it
out um come check out the work that we
have done and uh and we'd love your
contribution. you know, I think um
because I I truly believe that um you
know, for um you know, the the road to
AGI is AI coders and Rust is the best
language for AI coders to use. It's far
better for AI than say Python,
JavaScript. Okay. So, you know, so we
want to build um a larger knowledge base
and make this smarter and uh um make
more and create more functionalities for
other agents to use. So, um, thank you
very much and, uh, um, I hope I will see
you on GitHub.